some a difficult defeat yesterday but
you bounce back like Champions do with
this important Victory talk to us about
that well it was an absolutely
horrendous game of course I think I
played very badly I think elshon also
played very badly and I think he made
the last mistake but now I mean I was
very demoralized yesterday I mean it's
funny like I don't know why this loss
was so painful it didn't look like that
okay I made like one or two mistakes
lost you know that's sort of how most of
your losses go but just something about
the way it happened just really got to
me and today I I barely even prepared I
said I mean I I understood that by
playing E4 in the first move because
elshon had sort of played some sort of
random-ish lines in the first two rounds
that he hadn't played before against D4
I figured he would play something random
against D4 as well I didn't prepare much
I just thought to go in and play and he
definitely surprised you with the oh
Kelly yeah I mean of course this can't
possibly be good but I didn't really
feel like playing Against the Machine
For the First Time tried to go c41 D4 is
some of the mainlanders emergency three
being the best moves there are some line
C3 E6 D4 D5 and I thought I thought here
the or no sorry C3 D5 was the bothered
me if D5 E5 was quite an advanced French
but this one I was worried about D4 for
some reason
if I play e takes D5 we're sort of going
to get back no no here maybe it's fine
but like if I play 85 I'm sort of back
in some C3 Sicilian which
you don't want to play yeah I'm not it's
probably a good version for white but I
just sort of thought let's just
freestyle try to go G3 AT move uh two
and you said you played a bad game but
why did you feel that way what around
here I mean maybe I was overly
optimistic I sort of thought that his
setup doesn't make nearly as much sense
once the pawn is on A6 because you've
just got back to like a couple moves
prior rugby one like he also after Rook
B1 Castle B4 like if his Pawn were on A7
he could just completely ignore me and
just BC DC he just doesn't care at all
but here because I will have Knight A4
uh at the ends and B6 is weakened and
you can't play B6 he can't defend C5 he
can't stop Knight B6 there's actually a
little bit of annoyance so like because
if his Pawn run itself in here I might
just prefer black just H6 B6 F5 send the
Death Star and you know what am I gonna
do but here this was kind of reply I
thought I should be better after he
played after he traded everything and
then A5 Bishop A3 I thought I should be
better but somehow yeah here I thought
this felt nice for what A4 is better for
black one more smoking does my palm not
get to C6 from I just completely insane
let's see it just doesn't care you go I
go
yeah I'll just go Rook C1 and get ready
to take D6 and slam on see like somehow
I'm worse here
I told you it was a bad game
don't trust the engine I've been
watching this type of position it's
probably pretty balanced for a while and
then
and then he played this move uh Bishop
to E5 yeah well I think already he was
screwing this up like after a rookie
after a rookie two I mean
just takes C3 and mega draw and I think
it's not even close together yeah and
when he played E3 like already I was
wondering because if I go H3 it's a dead
draw like H3 Bishop C3 take take Rook B2
Rook C5 King E2 this is just a draw and
so like it felt like as long as I have
this option he has no business playing
E3 and once he did it with his slime
thing done I thought all right this this
looks like fun let's give it a try so
Rook E3 and I believe hang on there's
some interesting lines here so if he
plays Rook G4 instead of Bishop H2
because this looks very attempting
there's rookie five win yes yes but Rook
F4 Chuck was an in-between move and yeah
here I win but Rook F4 Chuck was an
in-between no no not here before
this was where it was interesting
check this one I was not sure about and
then take
yeah I think I think you can install it
yeah and then D6 Rook G2 check King E3
Rook G1 I believe C4 is only winning
move
and check again you're gonna have to
find C4 sooner or later yes it's okay
and C4 I believe is only a winning move
with the point that Rook do and I'll
have Bishop D2 so he goes King F7 no
well here I go C5 but he'll go King F7
and now I have to go C5 now D7 work D1
and I lose but five and I'm just in time
King E8 C6 yeah and then I go yeah I'm
just in time so I was calculating that
and then the way he played I thought it
was just sort of losing I didn't
um I don't know why he panicked here
just make some move like and definitely
notified can you care for example if F6
uh I think now he can play Bishop E5
remember no he still can't okay let's
see I'll take or you take on G4 first
yeah but no it's okay now it's just
gonna be the same thing same thing same
thing yeah actually it's a better
version now yeah um but no yeah I don't
know like F6 if you just make some move
instead of Bishop E5 like I don't think
he needs to panic at all just F6 just
yeah age six sure and I think this is
just a dead draw I don't think I can
make further progress but there should
be five on the last move Before Time
control is a nice gift and I think this
coin ending wins absolutely it does and
that is actually something that you take
pride in as well this long uh
calculations right you work a lot on
these type of positions yeah I mean
calculating well is important and I've
done a lot of training on that and queen
end games are all calculation there's
probably like five strategic themes to
understand total and then you know it's
all just calculation but I was actually
curious when um from the queen on game
came and he played King G8 which I
thought should just lose routinely I
thought here I'm just King E6 just wins
but if he goes King F6
this was not easy because he needs to
pitch this Pawn so he can start checking
them I thought it was here the best I
could find was Queen E6 check
King f8 and then say we go Queen F6
check King G8 and then Queen d8 check
and then Queen D7 check and King back
and I wanted to just go take this Pawn
on B5 now this was the best I could find
that's okay I thought with two pawns and
both further Advanced but this there's
still a lot of work this time when he
played King Jr thought as soon as I got
King E6 we're just done here yeah but
yeah that seems to be the case Sam
congratulations uh just before the rest
day how are you going to spend the rest
day
I haven't thought about that yet
probably I'll hang with Doug my manager
who's uh he's good people and then I
think a student of mine wrote to me that
I hadn't heard from 10 years so if
they'll see him but you know just take a
little time off even after this one it's
been a very rough first five rounds for
me but you know tournament's still young
absolutely guys any questions no uh
congratulations Sam enjoy your rest day
uh well earned